good morning gamers it's another
beautiful day
in minecraft and today is a very special
day isn't that right sven
that's right hey both cow play the music
okay keep playing vodka for many years
me and sven have built together this
structure
it's a structure that symbolizes the
power
of friendship the power of love and the
of perseverance i introduce to you
the giant meatball
that's right take it in take it in it's
all its glory
there is finally peace on earth
isn't that right chicken water sheep
died for this you know
he died to make this possible without
water sheep there would be no giant
meatball
why did i build a giant meatball you
might ask
for water sheep this meatball represents
everything that watersheep believed in
friendship loyalty trust
and all those good things that he stood
by
what if what the sheep was here alive
today
i know he would be proud no one loved
the meatballs more than mortar sheep
he was like a father to me he was like
the son that i never had
and i loved him i may have shown it in
weird ways when
i may have not always been the nicest
and you know what i'll admit
i may not always been perfect but my god
the meatball stands tall and i'm so
proud
to call myself i'm american i don't even
know
stop jumping in boatswain please
i know you're excited but i haven't even
showed look at the press cow over there
uh i haven't even shown you guys the
best bit
so i've been messing around with
redstone i've spent a lot of time with
this redstone and i god i hope it works
sorry sven you can't ride this it might
break you just gotta hit this
and then voila
baby it's as glorious on the inside
as it is on the outside italian leather
exterior
all handicrafted by one scandinavian
suite
this took a lot of time i'm not gonna
lie i think the elevator
took more time for me to build i thought
okay
cool i'll build an elevator that that'll
be i think
uh not it's not epic i mean it's
it's super fun like i love writing it i
want it
the idea was to have something go all
the way
all the way to the top like the very top
and i'm like
no i'm tired of farming piston steel
material i'm tired of the circuits
always messing up and i don't understand
why
but it works for it works pretty well
i'm like it's really fun to ride it
the thing is like spent stop teleporting
you scare me
what if sven rides it oh my god i never
thought he's probably too
short i think he's too short yeah
sorry sven you're too short haha let's
try it
the thing is i know you can build
elevators
probably way smarter i'll guarantee you
that
i just wanted to try it out myself
i know you i could probably do it easier
as well if i had the
the sticky pistons i don't have sticky i
don't have slime
i don't have a sticky ow i don't have
sticky poo poo all right i'm not going
near this place when it's dark
too many creepers have blown up my
circuits
too many times for me to leave it around
that dark all right i mean
it ain't happening all right but let me
show you seriously i had so much fun
building the elevator
like i know it's janky and whatever but
i i didn't realize
redstone was so fun to just mess around
with okay so
i want i want sun to ride it van come
here i want to see if it works i'll be
so happy
yeah sometimes sometimes he breaks
sometimes it breaks it's fine it's van
very hello
he's like stuck in the elevator it's
fine is he oh there you are okay
hey can you come down here it's a ball
inside of a ball what else do you want
baby
all right come on let's do this thing
cool inside the fence he teleports
all right so follow me i'm just gonna
put the leash on you sven because
you're being a little difficult
[Music]
yeah this is gonna be a problem all
right fine i'll make a special door for
you sven
sven you're being very difficult don't
be shy
it's gonna break the whole thing sven
please please please
go go no no
no i know you don't like tight spaces
anymore after what happened in 86
come on jiba liba never have kids
please thank you thank you spend is
going to go for a ride
listen i know you're scared of elevators
it's fine trust me
are you sitting all right here we go
three two one
[Laughter]
wow how was that sweat did you enjoy it
get your back wire down here all right
you can stand so basically
the way it works is it's a staircase
it's a glorified stair trace
one signal goes to the upper ones one
signal goes to the pusher ones
and they're one taken delay and then
i don't know it just took me a lot of
time to figure out how redstone works
isn't that right
and a lot of wool first i use stone and
i think like
the circus would still connect and i
didn't understand why and then i saw
other people use wool so i'm like okay i
guess i'll use wool
and then these add a delay even if you
don't add a delay to them which
added another mystery to the problem but
basically yeah it goes one two
three four sven where is he
there you are he's fine eat something
uh wait what happened here is it double
step here
is that even possible wait where's the
next step
it pushes here pushes here pushes here
it pushes you up there
[Music]
it still works apparently okay cool i
didn't know that was possible
let me try what
oh my god it skips the step that's
genius i don't even know what i built
so yeah i uh
it's so satisfying i love the sound
that's why it gets stuck sometimes my
god
i was planning to put carpet all around
here and maybe like put a floor here you
could have a really big floor
right and then i thought it could be
cool maybe can you do like catapults and
stuff because then like if i have the
organ here and we head out on adventure
we can catapult out there into the water
these are just ideas i have i want to
build sven i want to build it's so fun
to build i love minecraft
oh yeah jurgen is gone i forgot
i lost jurgen i've looked everywhere
sven
today we bring back jurgen he has to be
out somewhere
he wouldn't just excuse me excuse me
water cow
you are good for one purpose and one
purpose only actually two
playing music and your delicious juice
thank you oh that's right we're right
[Music]
minecraft just keeps on surprising i
didn't know you could do this
why can you do this
me and both cow forever and ever
going next adventure and drinking his
jew
damn that was beautiful thanks both cow
you're the best okay
i really miss watersheep i'm not gonna
lie i'm not over water sheep i'm not
over jurgen being lost
i'm not over anything i'm honestly hurt
i'm confused and you know depression
shows its way in many forms and
i chose to build a giant meatballs other
people
do other things okay but now that
meatball is built
i still feel the pain it's still there
let me see if i can find something else
like a substitute right
i need to make this right hello there do
you know what or she
i'll tell you all about it he was the
best it was like a father to me how did
you know that
you have for lava now don't want you to
get hurt
oh my god idiot cool
you just ruined my life okay never mind
you are the lucky new watersheet
it's an honor and a privilege where's
the bell
here we go oh my god the meatball
appears before ikea tower
my god it's so beautiful i was thinking
about putting a swedish flag on top
i just got really tired of farming it
looks kind of like a death star
or something cool i'm glad sven is
taking care of oh my god
i knew you were evil he's talking to
spider evil chicken
my god how can you do this chicken
[Music]
huh who am i kidding it's not the sames
man it's not the same
it doesn't feel as good as when water
sheep did it you don't squeal in pain
like water sheep
it's not the same it will never be the
same
we had was special all right there's two
water cows now because i'm too annoyed
that sven keeps entering
oh sorry sorry what are you doing
[Music]
you get to live so apparently you can
build like a
dispenser or something like that i want
to try that wait i think i have one
oh yeah it's right here see i thought
dispenser was
like a garbage bin or something clearly
not the case
i have a lever yeah this is all i need
so if i place dispenser
how does dispensers work there we go and
then i put like
so i can what are you doing how did you
escape don't look so innocent
oh gosh you people are there you go stay
there
do i just put a lever on it oh my god
what you'll never be water shaped
hey come on come on participate
you'll never have a watershed what
what don't go near him
he's evil that's right i see it in his
eyes
tell me where watersheep is
oh my god how does he do that oh what
ah stop
[Applause]
[Music]
you will never be watershed
why won't you die
it just becomes more of them what
no don't go there ah you all went there
[Music]
guys this is a restricted area you can't
no let's get up
there well aren't you adorable
fine all right enough playing around we
got actual stuff to do
it is 3am
[Music]
we are here to summon back watershed
minecraft spirits and gods notch can you
hear us
we want the water sheep back and you're
going to of course
i will ring this bell three times
we bring sacrifices on the third ring
i expect watersheeps return one
two
what the did you guys hear the door from
the nether portal
watershed water sheep
not water sheep he's not coming back is
he
[Music]
stop it guys he will never come back
sven i'm going to bed
and don't even try and console me
okay guys i think it's time we realized
watersheep is gone forever we need to
build a memorial
it's the least thing i can do this is
for water sheep
get out of the way can you not there it
is
you know i may i may have been partially
responsible for what happened
to watershed i may have done i'm not
perfect by any means
but i still love him that's right we
have gathered here today to say goodbye
to watershed no stop thank you i'll
continue spending well
that was it basically rest in peace
water sheep for some peace
may your wool forever be soaked in water
okay sven we may have lost water sheep
there's two people that we can still
retrieve sven
jurgen too and boneyard again are still
out there
we're gonna get them gosh darn it now we
need to make water drinking potion
and underwater seeing potion poor puffer
fish i'm sorry
it's the same dinner bone i'm sorry
i'm sorry then we have to make potion of
night vision so we can see
him golden carrot my god better be worth
it
let's extend it as well
it is done i'm bringing my lucky puffer
fish on the way
he'll guide the way to dinner bone come
on hurry
get in the boat then there we go oh it's
so cute
we're gonna get him back sven don't
worry oh god we're going near that place
no don't worry sven close your eyes
close your eyes it's fine
oh you look away that's right look away
nothing bad
over there oh there's a shipwreck here
what kind of wood is this
whoa i never seen this this is junk
jungle
it's jungle we've never been to jungle
okay but i have been
here or someone else probably water
sheep
we have so many places left to explore
in this game a thousand part series then
a thousand perfect it's getting dark
great
so i think it was yeah jurgen was over
there
and we swam from this island to here
so it had it must have happened
somewhere here in between oh
god it's gonna be difficult okay stay
and stay and hold the boats then
and i will look for uh i will drink this
and this gives me underwater drinking
and i need
there it is whoa i forget how awesome
whoa okay now we actually
whoa it's actually easier maybe i'll
stain it okay this is good phonier again
he's white too isn't it boneyard again
where are you we missed you
phone you're good are you out there
oh i saw something white dude i'm scandi
guys
honestly i know this is dora the
explorer but help me
if you spot did you guys see that am i
crazy
if you spot him you got satella bro i
swear i saw something in between here
sky freaking heal things right because i
went here tonight
where are you dinner
hello i'm pulling up my coordinates
so you guys can tell me what coordinate
if you see him
hello it's impossible i'm just gonna
scan over this area
because this is where i lost him no
no it's so dark
mission failed sven we'll get him next
time
buffer fish you did nothing explain
yourself
oh god come back i'm just kidding i was
kidding oh god
puffer i'm sorry oh i'm sorry
you don't look too good puffer
[Music]
oh my god oh my god
why are you here you just wanted to walk
oh my god how did you get here
i tried to find dinner bone and i found
real jurgen
epic oh my god yes
the series is saved the boys are back in
town
the boys are back in town gosh darn it
why did you leave me
i was so scared you're good number two
i'm literally lost on the way back home
i swear i've been here before
oh thank god we made it back oh
my gosh they're so beautiful i'm
teary-eyed i'm so happy
uh we'll find dinnerbone next time
jurgen i have to show you the giant have
you you haven't seen it complete
oh my gosh you disappeared while i was
building it
oh you stay there please all right
walter cow play the song
it's a song of jurgen and friendship
listen to this here again damn the base
though
yeah yoga is back in town baby
that's what i'm talking about
for those who don't know we have new
merch check out represent.com
pewdiepie and support jurgen and sven we
have sven at jurgen first that's right
good luck next time thanks for watching
another episode next time
we're gonna find the ender portal see
you then
bye bye what you never played two for
simulator
you know it's fun right i'm not supposed
to give my opinion
but give it a try and then you can tell
me if it's good or not
not convinced yet okay i'll cut you a
deal
the game is available for free and
that's a great price